can technology enhance your spiritual
walk
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness well welcome
everyone to another episode of led live
today is going to be a little different
as you can see there's a couple people
missing from the table
i feel like i'm so far away from you
guys it's a big hole a big gap
i know it seems like we should have a
couple more but we're gonna try to have
some fun anyway okay
so today we're gonna talk about
technology and
the bible something that i am personally
interested in
and i really like technology i don't
know about you guys but i like
technology
you like it makes things a lot easier
you know okay yeah like uh if i want to
you know since we're talking about the
bible often i can't remember
what verse that was in i can remember
like three
words in a sentence and i can search
that and oh there it is you know yeah
very helpful you know what's amazing
though when you read someone from the
1800s
and it's like they're writing spiritual
thoughts
about it and then they're just like
inserting bible verses in there dude
those people
knew those bible verses so as much as i
agree with you i
enjoy the search ability i think
sometimes it kind of makes me lazy
yeah okay i think it does too i've been
reading this book about william penn to
my kids
and he's the guy that was gifted from
king charles ii
the territory called pennsylvania
and um you know he he studied the law
some law and he um was a puritan for
part of his life
and in the book they're kind of
chronicling how
he would just quote like from his law
books like from memory and from the
bible from memory i mean you're talking
like
40 passages and you know at one time
just
incredible to think about that so i
think you're right i think technology
can make us lazy
for sure as much as i like it always in
the morning for myself
i always get my bible out and i put away
all the distractions i don't even use
technology for my morning devotion
yeah um i'm like that too when it comes
to like going to church i like to bring
my bible i like to make myself flip
through it and
just something nice about having the
physical copy but
you know when you're working on social
media and stuff and i'm like what was
that verse and
just swipe over to my bible the reason
is is because you may start with a good
intent but all of a sudden that email
pops up and you're like i should have
yeah texted this person
and like 20 30 minutes goes by you
didn't read anything
and you're off already to work wow yeah
so i like that time in the morning and
as much as i like technology i like
having hardback
books so i i have a tendency to just get
a hardback book because i
i don't know there's something about a
book i just really like but
technology's in my blood um i say that
my grandfather worked for
atnt his entire career
from like 17 to 62 he worked for at
t and the last seven years he worked in
their computer division
when they had this big shoot up in
southern california
guy went in and started you know using a
gun to like mow down computers and stuff
my grandpa was one of uh one of the guys
that was called in to
clean up that mess and you know set the
infrastructure back up i never heard
about that
um this is somebody who watched a lot of
terminators it was a long time ago
or something
five years ago plus right oh it's much
longer than that i mean you're talking
like probably
20 25 years ago and it was some guy that
just rolled into an office
and rolled into one of the yeah it was
pacific bell why was it that yeah
it was a long time ago what was the
motive like expensive
long distance plan or something i don't
know
the internet yeah i didn't know if it
might have been somebody that was like
these are gonna turn into terminators
and take over it could be
i'd have to look it up but um i have a
cousin that works for the u.n
in austria he's been there for
30 years 25 30 years something like that
he was the first person i can remember
when i got my first email account i
wanted to communicate with my cousin who
was in austria you know because you
could use email to do it
dude you need to have him go take
pictures of the alter room
totally different subject but i want to
see this ultra room
okay um
i don't know um what he does
like it's his exact job title i just
know he has diplomatic status and he
does not stand in long lines at the
airport
he goes to like one desk that like
nobody else gets to go to
and he just like goes right through wow
um i have another cousin he wrote
um at least one maybe two books on
computer science
that are required reading at some
college in california
my brother's an i.t guy one of my
brothers and of course
my son has strong tendencies in this uh
realm of life as well he and i are
actually starting to work on
a little coding project together so do
you dream in zeros and ones
i don't know so today i'm going to cover
some things a lot of things that i've
actually used
um to help me in my spiritual walk
and encourage you guys you know if
you're inclined that way to use them as
well it's not going to be an exhaustive
review by any means we're not going
in depth detail by detail but it's going
to be a brief overview
and it'll give you an idea of what's out
there and
you know i'm excited because we actually
have some
pretty substantial giveaways that we're
doing
uh for this program awesome so
i'm excited about that so a week from
when this airs we'll cut it off and
that'll be the end date but
you guys will want to check the
description below for this video it'll
have
the link to enter it'll have
probably links to the programs that
we're talking about all that kind of
stuff is going to be there
so one thing i want to stress though is
you
don't have to use and you don't need
technology
to have a great bible study or to
memorize the bible or to have a great
prayer life
it's completely possible without all
those things
but there are times i think that these
tools can make some of those things
easier as long as you know how to be the
master and not the slave
um the book of daniel in daniel chapter
12 verse 4 says this but thou daniel
shut up the words and seal the book even
to the time of the end
many shall run to and fro and knowledge
shall be increased
now i've heard this text talked about
many times
but what i think is really interesting
is
you know a lot of people will use this
and preach in prophecy seminars like
look the closer we get to the end of
time
the more knowledge just in general will
increase
and i think there's some truth to that
but the way this text is written and
what it actually
means and is referring to is biblical
knowledge
so the closer and closer we get to the
end of time biblical knowledge
will increase and sometimes i think
technology can help us dig deeper and
find those extra
to nuggets to increase our our biblical
knowledge i've heard also that the
the running to and fro is more like a
biblical study than
travel right right then travel like
going on airplanes and boats and all
that kind of stuff yeah i've heard that
too
the bible also says in proverbs 1 7 it
says the fear of the lord is the
beginning of knowledge but fools despise
wisdom
and instruction so the bible is our
source of instruction it's our source of
wisdom
and we need to mine that thing like
none other to get all the gems that are
out of it
and so when you are evaluating any kind
of
piece of technology i like to evaluate
it by two questions the first question
is is it a tool
or is it a toy all right
because if it's a tool great it can be
used for
to do some good and i'm in control of
that tool
if it's a toy though is something that
brings amusement
it doesn't really help me be productive
and likely it's going to control me
instead of the other way around
so you know why do i have
a smartphone is it a tool or a toy right
well for me it's a tool
not a toy so if it's a toy i really
don't need it
so we're going to talk first about bible
study
and each one of these sections that
we're going to go over i'm going to open
with a scripture and then we're going to
talk about some
specific examples the bible says it says
your word is a lamp unto my feet and a
life
unto my path how does the bible guide
you
i i think it gives you sort of the big
picture even the fine detail but
sort of the big picture of why things
are the way that they are
things maybe that you can't see from
your vantage point
so in that sense like a road map
shows you i can't go look down the road
and see where it turns right left right
left right left but if i look at a map i
can go oh i'm over here
and i need to get over here how about
you how does the bible guide you
yeah i think it you know there's a lot
of historical records and things like
that like we we get a lot of comments
from people like well the bible has evil
things in it and violence and all that
but
i think it's showing you look this godly
man went down this
path and look where it led him so don't
do that you know and it's
it's just got a lot of good information
um a lot of good
guidelines for your life treat others
the way you want to be treated you know
you you sew what you reap reap what you
saw yeah yeah and
yeah good point like any book it's going
to give you a
problem solution yeah but then there's
also examples exactly that's a good way
to look at it
i read this text and i think okay the
bible's a lamp
so if the bible's a lamp and it's a
light so that i can see where i'm going
the implication is the whole world
is in darkness and if i'm going to go
if i'm going to be able to see how to
move forward without
falling without stumbling without making
these
huge mistakes then i need the bible to
for that light so i can see where i'm
going and not you know succumb to those
things
so let's talk about this app you guys
have heard of the bible app by you
version
there's a little brown icon and it says
holy bible on it if you use that yeah
everybody's got it like everybody
probably has their phone
same sort of thing look at that like a
bible in every home bible on every phone
but people don't read it
yeah not even you don't even have to be
at your house you know you can just
wherever you're at the airport or
whatever yeah the bible literally
is so easy to get a hold of really of
any book
it's amazing this is the one that has
so many thousands probably millions of
downloads um
you know it's free it's the one i think
it's the go-to one on like every app
store if you just want a bible
there's a lot packed into this thing you
can read you can listen you can
watch i mean i think they are hooked up
with the
lumo project and some other projects
where you can watch parts of the box
yeah is this the one that
you can kind of click through and see
history stuff and i mean it's got it's
packed full of all kinds of things you
can make
little scripture pictures and you know
you can share your bible verse you can
highlight
you can do all kinds of stuff with it
and it's free and it's a great resource
and if you're just looking for
an electronic bible it's hard to beat
this thing you know for just
basic hey i want to look something up
there it is you've sold me
i have a something called quick bible
and it's just real simple but
i like that i can search a phrase and
it'll find
that i i'm sure this can do that too
right yeah it can search
i mean it it does most things
right as far as a basic bible app it's a
little bit of what it looks like here
um you know you can
see it's got a really a really i guess a
good
interface you know it's easy it's
intuitive
um you can pray privately or ask
friends to pray which i think is a nice
feature to bake into it as well
how does that work everybody that has
this app is kind of connected in a way
you have an account so you have to
create an account with it
and so then yeah you you can like friend
people and
and all kinds of it'll do way more than
that it has like one
really cool feature i've been tempted to
try out so many times but i've never
done it
um but i'm getting to that so i don't
want to get ahead of myself too much but
um you know has daily devotions and
um reading plans and
all kinds of stuff so you can you know
exchange stuff back and forth with
friends and like i said you can make
these nice little shareable
bible verses with a picture and nice
fonts and you can change the font and
you know place things and you know share
that on your social media or something
so it's it's pretty cool they have a
website
and um on the website they also have the
bible there as well and it's very clean
easy to navigate
has some other features that are really
cool
for example you know everything's
interlinked you have all these
references
you have an announcement module
there are um well they bill it as like
cost savings
you can and i think the reason they bill
it is cost savings is
it has a a website that's
hooks into this thing that is an events
um
like module i guess you would call it so
you can title your event
say where it's at when and all that and
more or less like launch your event and
people can join that event
from their phone using this app and then
in there you can put in
your bible references you can put in
your slides you can put in
other handouts this subject here's what
i'm gonna
yeah you can have all that stuff in
there and your audience can really just
follow along
as we're doing that
hey this friday we're doing it's and
it's been available for
years and i've been so tempted but you
know you have to build
it just like anything else like if
you're building a presentation it's kind
of that same thing so
so they're kind of like building it for
people who would do like home bible
studies but over like the internet i
mean
yeah i mean it's really cool or churches
or yeah
small groups or what have you there's
endless possibilities probably there
so it's a really neat feature and it's
free i mean that's the thing about
youversion is
all of this stuff is free now there's
probably some way it's not free i mean
who
i don't think they're selling your data
um they're probably able to market to
you and advertise to you in in some way
shape or form
or maybe you know the fact that they
have a popular app and
other people want to jump in on their
app maybe that's how they
they fund it but if you just want
something for basic
bible study you want to look something
up you need a quick quick reference
it's a really good tool to make that
happen and it's available on a lot of
platforms uh you can get on your your
iphone
your ipad your android device or a
kindle fire
so um sorry windows you guys didn't make
the code on that one
but it's also available on the web so
you can go to the website and
um check it out there
but if you want a more
serious bible study
software you have to go you want to go
deeper you know you want to know
the greek and the hebrew and interlinear
and and
strong's uh information
then you're gonna need some different
tools okay because
as great as the bible uh by you version
is
it's not it's not that kind of tool so
we're going to talk about some of those
tools
but first the bible says i rejoice at
your word as one who finds
great treasure so the bible's like
finding great treasure
why would you say that because uh
you have to kind of search the bible for
references and stuff
like i know a lot of times people will
be like oh this one verse says
this but it's like but really to get a
whole context of it you gotta
read what's before it what's after it
take maybe that word and search for it
in other parts of the bible because
the bible tells us to study line upon
line precept upon precept here a little
there a little
and i think that is because we don't
speak
the way people did in the bible days so
maybe we might read something a little
bit differently than it was
intended but the bible kind of
interprets itself so
find another place in the bible that
says something similar and
get a better context one thing i think
god created this
like complicated well he didn't he
didn't just
create it for the sake of like okay i'm
gonna make this really hard thing that
you guys need to figure out i think he
created
a a tool for us to endlessly be
odd at how amazing he is i think that
this thing will be studied and studied
and studied and throughout thing
so this is a massive deep hole that you
could never find the bottom of basically
right
the living word it never gets old yeah
so you think about like somebody that's
you know finds a diamond in the ground
cool i found a diamond you could cash
out and go right there but what if they
went back and they went hey dude there's
probably a lot more in here
and then they get all this machinery and
they dig this massive hole and now you
pull
millions and millions of stuff out of it
i don't know i assume that this is kind
of what
that's like you can have these tools
that'll you know get a shovel
dig a little hole you might find some
gems there but if you got the machine
you can get deep yeah good illustration
so question for you guys
have you ever used bible study software
you guys already mentioned a couple ones
if so which ones
and do you have any recommendations for
our viewers
i've used logos okay i've heard of logos
you've used logos
just the basic like the app yeah i
didn't buy any of the extra tools and
stuff that go along with it um
it was pretty detailed as it is um
i i kind of sometimes i'm i'm
more on the cheaper side so i'll use
internet tools if i need to know the
greek or whatever like this there's
websites and stuff like that
this makes it really nice because you
can compile your study
and then store stuff away highlight
stuff organize
it and and it's like all in one little
nice package but i
i build slides for presentations so i
kind of use the
keynote as my builder and i'm just
finding the information and storing it
in there so
but i have used it it's a nice tool okay
well let's talk about e-sword have you
guys heard of e-sword yeah
e-sword is really the bible software i
probably cut my teeth on
um started out on windows it was free
still is free
very customizable and i even made a lot
of my own modules at the time
uh when i mentioned that what could you
do for it so
it has um you could make like your own
it has like a study center or at least
you used to and i haven't used it for
like
15 years but you could um put in like
your own book
or your own like yeah
yeah it would have to be the plain text
and then you could go through and link
the scriptures
so that when you pulled up that tool
everything was there you
you uh mouse over the scripture and it
would like pull it up and
it's just kind of like make it more
interactive yeah kind of
um so yeah i had some
books that i was interested in materials
i was interested in having right there
instead of other places and so i i got
you so like put them in there if there's
a certain scripture
and it's highlighted a different way you
can hover over it and like it'll pop it
it'll pop up the script
you like or something yeah right there
like that
so it's pretty cool but i i made the
decision to
move to a mac um
probably a little bit after i got
married and
there was a port it's what's called a
port of e-sword
called max sword and
i didn't think it was very well done i
tried to use it a bunch of times it was
okay
so i went looking for other tools and
i'll talk about those
a little bit later but e-sword you can
get on you know your mac your
ipad your iphone the windows one is free
but the other stuff is not the developer
actually charges for that
and so it's packed full of features you
know you can get a parallel bible it has
this integrated editor i was talking
about
you got the strong's tool tips
scripture tool tips just all kinds of
stuff it has a reference library
powerful searching if you want they have
some library of audio sermons probably
nothing i would
really listen to but it's there if you
want and
a graphics viewer so if you want to you
know zoom in on some maps or
check out you know what's the holy land
look like or where was this or where was
that
the strong's maybe just in case somebody
is just not even familiar with what that
means
the concordance strong's concordance so
when you're reading the bible it's been
translated to english
from either hebrew aramaic or the greek
and a lot of times you like
our language just isn't big enough to
try and encapsulate some of these words
so
sometimes i really enjoy like looking up
what does this word mean in the greek of
the hebrew which is what the strong
concordance does
and it's it's really interesting when
you find out like wow this word really
means a lot more than
i thought it did in the english and just
one that comes to the top of my head is
like
the word that's just interpreted hell in
the bible is actually
hades scheel
what are the other ones tartarus
tartarus and
yeah that's right and so sometimes you
read stuff and you're like
wow david's in hell or something but
it's just like the grave so
you can kind of get mixed up when you
just read like the english translation
so i
i enjoy the concordance yeah
so like i was saying they have an app uh
it's very similar to
their you know windows software or mac
software
it's pretty easy to use i mean just the
fact that has a strong concordance in it
is is very useful and
can make your bible study really really
deep
has the graphics viewer in it and they
try to make it
as easy as possible to navigate this
thing the other thing that i really
appreciate about e-sword is has a very
active community that surrounds it and
you can find lots of free and paid
modules that
integrate into it so one website i put
on the screen is
e studysource.com
so if you use e-sword you might check
that out you might find some tools there
that you
really like and there are just a ton of
things that you can
plug into e-sword to make it that much
more powerful
so again i've already mentioned iphone
ipad mac those are all
charged for but windows
uh you can download and get it for free
now another one i want to talk about is
blue letter bible if you guys heard of
that one
i think it's been around for a long time
yeah that's a great um
online resource and i will use that from
time to time
so for example i'll just show you like
what i did for the audience
i put in a search term on on there
and then you know like i put in the word
jesus brought it up and then it
shows me where jesus is used in the
bible and then
i can look at the inner linear
and i can see okay well this is the
received text what is jesus
in this particular scripture it shows me
like how everything looks in the greek
how to pronounce it how to parse it what
the strong's number is
just all this wealth of information
i like how you when you use this one um
it can kind of show you where else it
was used
because if you see like okay they use
this in this context
in this verse but then they used it over
here
sometimes when you read the other
context of the other things too you're
like oh okay well that's what he was
meaning by that you know mm-hmm that's
something i enjoy too
because it you know it can be hard to
like
search every single word in the greek
and the hebrew in a concordance but when
you look at like
i don't know like this i guess that
website offers the same verse and
multiple
different translations and you can kind
of see them all on the same page
yeah i don't know if you can see them
all on the same page it might have a
parallel
but you know it's really easy to switch
back and forth
so sometimes if like you read something
the king james you're
like i don't really understand what that
means and you look at the new king james
it's a little bit modified and then
i like comparing it to the other ones
and be like oh well
i'm seeing a common consensus with this
maybe it's closer to
this translation and then you might want
to go to the greek in the hebrew just to
really pin it down so i don't know if
you guys know but there's also
an app for blue letter bible so you can
get that on your phone so
same tools that are available on the
website are available on the app and
this
is also free so you know you have the
advanced searching the verse tap menu
the greek and hebrew interlinear do you
know if it works offline
i do not know if it works offline that's
a good question
we'll have to investigate that and uh
maybe put in a little uh
insert on our video to let our viewers
know it works offline
um it has the treasury of scriptural um
knowledge which i'm i'm trying to
remember it was that
a uh charles spurgeon did he put that
together
i don't remember but it's it's like uh
um how would i describe that it's like
a chain reference on steroids
i mean it just has tons of references
for whatever verse it's like
just the bible interlinked so
it's available on the web iphone ipad
and
android and that's how you can get it
accordance bible have you guys heard of
that one i have not heard of that one
you've not heard of that one
i think i know why you've heard of that
one because i've been using it for years
i sit next to him and and as does he's
pulling up
yeah this is the one that i that i
transitioned to
um not too long after i got a mac i met
a pastor
um name is jeff wines at the time
man i don't remember what conference
video he was in but he was visiting our
church
and he had a mac and i was curious like
well what do you use
and he had used this and you know i'll
try it out
and i really liked it um there's a lot
of things
i like about accordance it's very
simplistic
it's very bible centric
you can easily get those interlinear
tools
the greek the hebrew you know all of
that and
it's just the search is very powerful
i like to use what's called a logical
operator so a logical operator when
you're searching is something called
like a term that's and so you might you
know
type jesus and spirit
and it'll bring up all the verses in the
bible where those two
words are in the same verse you can also
use
or um you can use
uh you can use those in combination like
jesus and spirit
or um you know another word instead of
spirit holy spirit holy ghost and then
it would list every verse in the bible
that had
those combinations so i like to do that
kind of stuff
[Music]
but really fast very fast at searching
and search capabilities are probably the
number one feature that i
look for when i'm using bible study
software because
chances are at least part of the verse
is in my head and i just can't quite
remember how
the whole thing was said and i want to
you know
quickly you know pull that out so i'll
type a phrase or part of a phrase
bring it up and there it is and then i
can copy it and use it in another
program like you're talking about
um so accordance is
is very good mac software they
were only mac software for a long time
and then more recently
they have uh made it available for
windows as well so now you can get it on
either one and this is free on all
platforms they have
a free version so the free version is
basic
it's the king james and i think it comes
with the strongs
and there's not a
whole lot more to it there's a few like
you know public domain resources you can
plug into the thing
that search feature though oh yeah the
searching yeah that's that's really cool
when you said you can do like this
or that yeah that's really smart yeah i
like that
can you do that though with like um
bibledictionary.com
i think there's some key commands they
might have that capability where they
have logical operators yeah
i think there is on that online version
because my
my simple bible app thing is called uh
i don't remember what it's called right
now quick bible if
those words if i put three words in
there it will not show me a verse that
doesn't include those three words
but i like the capability of like well i
wasn't sure if it said holy spirit or
holy ghost
you know that's cool yeah
this is what they say you know they're
very uh bible-centric you open the
software and
you see the bible i mean that's it
and i there's a specific reason i
mentioned that um
and like i said i've been using this for
years i have it on my phone
the app is pretty good i'll
one of the ways the search is kind of
built on is it's very flexible you can
either type in a word and it'll search
for the word or you can type in the
reference
and it'll find the reference so it has
what's called a flex search and you can
you know just type whatever you're
looking and it'll figure out is this a
word i'm looking for is it the reference
and you can use the short code for
references so you don't have to type
first thessalonians you can type 1 th
you know 5 12. and it'll
so really quick is it kind of got some
cloud capabilities with whatever you're
doing on your phone
gets translated down the line to the
computer so the cloud capabilities is
that if you put in
notes or highlights or things like that
you can sync those to the cloud you can
sync them to like dropbox
or to icloud and then it will sync
across your devices so you kind of need
a third-party
um like cloud service
it's not baked into their service no
they don't have their own cloud service
so which some people prefer and some
people
yeah you know would rather just use
their
their existing cloud service so
there's some screenshots of what the app
looks like and the capabilities
of what it will do um
most every tool that's very i guess what
you call serious bible software is going
to have
you know the greek and the hebrew the
interlinear
it's going to have you know dictionaries
you know like easton's bible dictionary
it'll have commentaries
um and again you can make your own
modules with this thing or build your
own sermons inside of it
and you know make it so you can link
things back and forth so
it has you know the typical app features
like dark mode and that kind of stuff
you can change the way that it looks
which isn't the most important part but
some people are interested in that but
if you are a mac
person i would really encourage you to
try accordance out and i wouldn't
discourage you if you're
windows-based either there are many
things about this
that i really like and like i mentioned
they have a free version
so if you want some basic serious bible
study software
i would not hesitate to give accordance
a shot
um one of the things i am really excited
about today
is that i reached out to accordance and
i told him hey look
i am a longtime user of your software
and i'm going to be doing this show and
i told them what the show was about i
told them about our youtube channel
you know how many subscribers we had and
i said would you be willing to
either give a discount code or a you
know something free to
our user base and so they got back with
me and they said yeah
in fact they decided to
let one person win their triple learner
collection
which is a better collection than i have
um you're gonna have to enter and that's
that's okay um i've kind of
built pieced mine together with the
stuff that i want in it
but this is about 400
if you were to buy it which they say is
about 17 to 1900
worth of bible study resources so it's
not going to
be just the bible you're going to have
all the
greek and hebrew tools probably multiple
because there's more than just strongs
there's
other tools like that other lexicons
it will have commentaries and other
books a lot of times you'll have stuff
like
pilgrim's progress bundled in and you
know treasury of scriptural knowledge
and
all these kind of things it probably has
some kind of graphics package that's
built into it
likely you will get several bible
translations if that's something you're
interested in
so i'm excited that we can give you guys
um something like that i mean it's
pretty cool to be able to use our
channel to be
able to give away something like that so
this is available on your phone your
ipad your mac
and windows if you're just wanting to
get the base
software like you beyond the free
version like you want like the starter
package
it's like 50 bucks and one time you just
own it
yeah i mean on most software models
these days
they're one time but what that means is
you get a year's worth of
upgrades so after a year if they come
out with another version you don't get
the new version
um you know you have to pay for that
so i've upgraded multiple times they've
gotten
my money many times over so all right
now you mentioned
logos and we're going to talk a little
bit about logos today
so i just took some of these screenshots
from their website
and this isn't really important but
doesn't the word mean something
biblical logos yeah i think it just
means
word the word yeah yeah word in the
beginning was the
logos oh yeah okay so
uh in the world of bible software i
would say logos is considered to be
the best they're the one who's supposed
to be top-notch anybody who's anybody
uses this thing
it probably has more things
in this that you will never use like
it's just
packed full of stuff um pretty powerful
software i even
seen recently like their newest version
you could
like scan a bible reference and it would
like bring it up on your phone or
something it was
like crazy technology that's great yeah
it's an episode yeah yeah jet
so for example here it says like search
jesus in the online bible and you'll
you know um miss out 4165 results
because they're taking into account
everything not just searching
like if it said he when it's referring
to jesus but don't use the word
so they're like taking all of that into
account
um i tell about a month or two ago i'd
never used this
um but we reached out to them about
another product that we were thinking
about using as part of our show
and when we reached out to them i
started talking to them about this
program we were doing
and said hey you know i reached out to
your
logos bible division about this program
and i didn't hear anything
and they said oh we need to fix that so
they put me in contact with somebody
and um you know they had some customer
service rep
and they said well you know it's great
you want to be talking about
logos bible software but we want you to
talk about it
only if really you've used it because we
want
you know you to be confident in what
you're talking about so for the last
month or two
i've been using the logos bible software
i put it on my phone
and i have it on my computer at the
office this computer here
and they come to me a decent license
told them you know i was in school for
theology and all that and
so they quickly remedied the situation
and
i got started using it and i'll tell you
it's very
powerful software i downloaded the app
on my phone
so i use it you know when i'm pulling up
stuff with my kids
the app is pretty i would say pretty
intuitive
it's uh very easy to use it has you know
super powerful
um you can design your own reading plan
it has all the standard you know
features you would expect in a serious
bible
study app um but to be honest i
have to be honest when i and i told them
this so i'm not saying anything that i
haven't told them
when i first launched the desktop
software i could not find the bible
and i was like okay i've used a lot of
software
and i learned software pretty quickly
but this was not intuitive at all i mean
i launched i'm like
how do i access the bible and
um i figured it out i didn't have to
google it or watch a video
um and then you know things got better
because once you launch
the bible then it stays up and you kind
of you know you had to figure out how to
get it going initially
but i gave them that feedback pretty
immediately and i said you know
the bible should be very centric to
bible study software
the fact that i had trouble finding it
in
accessing and using it was kind of
alarming to me
so i hope that they take that feedback
seriously
and make the bible more centric to their
at least the initial user impression
because what i got was
this dashboard full of all of these
things
that were like okay that's nice and
interesting some of them i was
interested some of them not
but at the end of the day i just wanted
to be able to search the bible
and see you didn't get the uh the neuro
link
added i did the thing that just i did
not get that
it puts the whole bible in your brain
this is why you mentioned about the
previous program when you open it it's
very
bible very bible central it's like
you know it was it's super easy you got
a search bar right above the scriptures
you know what you're gonna get
i i would agree um i think maybe a
helpful thing and i don't know
actually would search this um software
recently or thing but if you could sort
of like
simplify it yeah you know what i mean
like like i
i'm thinking of it like an edited
editing tool right you can you can make
premiere you know change this box put it
here do this make you can simplify that
that thing based on the tools that you
need i don't know if that has that
capability but that would be a neat
feature
oh like go to view mode and maybe yeah
it's like you can kind of customize it
to the way your brain works
because you're going to want different
things than me and and you can do some
of that you can actually customize um
the dashboard and the way you know what
it brings up
and what's available initially excuse me
um
so just being honest when i first
started using the app
uh initially i actually hated it i did
not like it at all and i
i was
[Music]
i was used to something else and i think
that was the biggest problem like i've
been using accordance for
10 years probably
but i didn't give up i kept i kept at it
i i kept questioning like well why did
they do it that way like why did they do
it this way
and um after using it for a month or two
i can see why they did some of the
things that they did like it makes a lot
more sense to me now
and i'm pretty close to saying that
i actually prefer their app to
accordance's app
um i'll just give you a simple example
and you can you can do this in
accordance but it's not the way i was
using accordance so in accordance i just
everything is built around the search so
if i'm going to look something up
i'll put in a scripture
and maybe i need to look up multiple so
you put it in comma put the next one in
comma put the next one in
pulls them all up right just one right
after another
logos doesn't do that and it
what you have to do is it has something
called a passage list
so it's a different like screen you add
the scriptures to the passage list
and then you have them all on one screen
one thing that it will do and i don't
know if accordance will do this or not
but on
logos when you make that passage list
you can
save that passage list now for future
reference
which is a really cool feature but you
can't just
like when you have the bible up and
you're like typing a scripture in
you can't type multiple you just type
the the verse or the chapter or whatever
and it brings that up you're not getting
multiple one right after another
in that initial screen um so you can
basically
save a whole like collection of verses
on
heaven or whatever yeah and add to that
yes that's cool
and eventually i plan on doing that for
my devices because
you know if i want all those scriptures
on a particular topic i want to be able
to bring it up
especially if somebody calls the
ministry and they have a question about
whatever what about this what about this
what about this and it's all right there
um so another thing is you know because
it's
accordance is so search
centric uh i was used to just typing the
verse in and that's how i got to it you
know whatever it is just
type in the reference there it is and
you can switch how that works
but logos um you can type it in
but i actually a lot of times almost
prefer it has like this little hud panel
where you
you tap an icon and it brings up all the
books
and um where you can tap on them you
know it's just like there's they're like
in their own little squares
so you tap the book tap the chapter tap
the reference done
so it's like three taps and you're there
it's like
you know if you're on a small device i
can see where that would be really handy
because it's harder to type on a
on a little keyboard and again
accordance has that but i don't have
mindset kind of default that way
where you can do that so
i kept using it and i actually there's a
lot of things i actually
really like about it so
still getting used to the desktop
software i like the features it's a very
integrated experience so i like the fact
that
when i start to search something
if it's a story a miracle an event it
starts to auto detect that
and bring up the passage for me
everything in context as a link
tells me what it is and all i have to do
is click on it like i didn't even have
to start
i don't even have to finish typing what
i'm typing like you if you type like
jesus he
before you can finish it it's like
looking up all the verses where he
healed somebody or something
yeah or like um jesus if i wanted to
type like jesus
miracle or jesus first miracle it was
like and it would bring up jesus first
miracle here's where it's at
john and you click on it and it takes
you to the whole
context that is cool so that's really
neat
um i really like that jesus baptism
i also like the fact that when you're
reading through the bible
especially the gospels let's say uh
there's a
parallel passage because everything's
broken up
everything's in section headings you
know kind of breaks it up that way
if that section is in another one of the
gospels
or two of the gospels or three of the
gospels all of those references are
listed at the top you can just click on
them and go right to it and read it
and nice and see it right there so
that's a really
really cool feature um
but um so for this program
what's really neat they have decided to
give one of our winners
what's called their bronze package logos
nine
and that would cost you about 630
dollars
if you were to buy it cool it has
thousands of dollars worth of resources
in it it's probably more stuff than
you'll ever use or need
and i'm just you know i'm pretty stoked
that they
kicked down six hundred and thirty
dollars worth in the uh license that's
software so it's like
you know what is it what is it really
worth or cost it doesn't cost them any
extra but
the fact that they you know they say
that it's this has value and i think it
will have value to somebody else
whoever's using it so
again you guys can enter to win this
software and
uh we will like to get uh get you hooked
up
i think i need a license so i can
intelligently talk about it
as well yeah well we might be able to
arrange that
um also like accordance and some of
these others they have a free version so
if you just want to explore their
software and get started in
deeper bible study they have that they
have a basic package you can get started
with and i don't remember it's either
it's either like 20 or 50 or something
like that
uh very similar in in price point and
and features
it's available on like everything i mean
you can get on your facebook
your ipad your mac android windows
kindle fire it
and pretty much you name it they make it
for it i don't think xbox
so and they also have a web component
so if you have an account you can go to
the web get your same resources
hook everything up and they are more
than just bible study software that i
think the parent company is called faith
life
so they have things for your church you
know presentation software
and they have actually have not that we
would
ever recommend this but they have a
whole section
for movies and tvs and documentaries you
know a lot of christian based resources
for media
we haven't checked those out so we
couldn't recommend them to you just
to understand what you meant about
web-based does that mean
like if you don't have your laptop but
you're at the library you can still
access this stuff i think so
yeah i haven't tested that uh really in
depth
but yeah that's cool yeah and you know
you can get stuff on subscription and
they have all kinds of products so check
them out faith life
logos nine all right moving on
you guys ever use an audio bible all the
time
audio bio okay all the time what do you
use youtube
okay youtube i used to use the niv
reading because it kind of like added a
little bit of music and it was a little
bit dramatized and stuff
um and then i like the old schoo
alexander scurvy yeah i just like his
voice you know
sometimes i'll listen to that one i like
this verse in
romans 10 17 that says so then faith
comes by hearing
and hearing by the word of god amen
so i've used this software called
bible.is it's
mac based it's an app put it on your
phone
i used to have a commute that was a half
an hour to work
one way and i would put that on play it
in the morning
and just listen to bible and i did that
day in day out for
years yep i want to kind of comment on
this section as well because
that's that's really how i got a lot of
bible knowledge as well when i lived in
los angeles
um often i'd work on these shows that
were you know 45-minute hour drives
it is amazing how much bible you can
cover just driving around
and so you know it's like yeah you can
kind of listen to music
and whatever it's not really going to do
much for you other than maybe lift your
spirits
this can just feed you there and back to
work all the time
do something productive with that boring
drive i do it
every day i drive an hour to work both
ways and sometimes it's
two hours through rush hour getting back
home and yeah i do a lot of the
youtube bible youtube this must be
watching youtube
well it's just alexander talking
i'm more of an auditory learner so if i
hear something
i generally remember it so like if
somebody tells me a joke i've probably
pretty much got it first shot and can
tell you you know from there on out
um so this is really good for people who
are auditory learners
you know listen to the bible over and
over and over again and this thing is
available
in so many languages
i mean it's it's amazing how many
languages they have
the audio bible in and different
translations if that's if that's your
thing
so um i really encourage you to check
out
bible.is or bible.is
however they um say it it's available
for iphone ipad and of course android
now let's talk about memorization um
i i want to agree with scotty like at
the beginning of the show we were
talking about you know why are our
memories
so poor it's probably because we rely on
uh some of these technologies too much
or um you know like for example
used to be you could spell all right
i feel like i can't hardly spell anymore
you know because
everything is auto correct you know tell
you if you did it wrong you just right
click and change it
or you're just talking to your phone you
don't even yeah
and you miss a few keys and you get to
it just fixes it yeah i'm just like
it'll figure it out so in some ways it's
almost like
man it's like we're getting illiterate
well the bible does tell us your word
have hidden in my heart
that i might not sin against you it
tells us that we are supposed to hide
god's word in our heart
and you know different people have
different ways of doing that we're going
to talk about a few of those i'm going
to talk about a couple of
apps and the reason i'm talking about
the apps is
is not to you know counteract what i
said
just a few minutes ago but they can
involve
multiple senses and i think that's
really important when you're trying to
remember something generally the more
senses you it involve the more
likely you are going to remember it so
several years ago there was this app
called scripture typer
and it hit the app store and it was
pretty popular later on they changed
their name to
bible memory so here's their website
and they are pretty much the number one
bible memory app
their philosophy is um
type it memorize it master it right
neat thing about this is you can get
into groups
you don't ever lose your verses you stay
organized it kind of
tracks like how well your memory is
doing it reminds you to review them so
you keep it
in your mind all the time has a bible
integrated so if you just want to read
the bible it's there
[Music]
you can memorize with other people so
that's what i'm saying about the groups
like you can join this group and let's
say they're trying to memorize
um first john you can you know join that
group and then
get to work this is the app that we all
got gifted here right
it is we all got gifted pro accounts i
really enjoyed it i i say enjoyed
because i haven't
done it in a little while i need to but
i do like that when you open it up it's
like hey you remember this first it's
like
right on there like this is the one
you're studying last night let's do it
again
and you do you have to keep going
because i had
a lot of i was like okay the only verse
like
no like really good is john 3 16 like
everybody so
i was like i just want to learn all of
john 3 so i was getting
pretty good i memorized i think before
john
3 16 like maybe john 15 down to like 21
and i was just like i was getting pretty
good at it but
um like anything like exercising you got
to keep on it because you'll forget
but i like how it works i don't know if
you're going to go into how it works
like how it looks i mean go ahead i
might um so basically
it'll show you the whole verse and you
can like read it and then
it'll show you the whole verse but
there'll be like five words missing and
when
you're reading you get to that oh sorry
for god so love the
and then you just type w and it fills it
in because it knows like
you basically got it yep and then the
next one would be like for god's love
the world he gave his only begotten
s son but as you do it like two or three
more times
there's like nothing on the screen and
you're you're typing the first letter of
every word
that's really helpful i like that's it
were you gonna say something
no i just think that the memorization
you know i know we've kind of made a few
jokes about not being able to remember
things down the road but flash cards
have been proven to to remember stuff so
this is this is a really neat tool
and i think like you know you don't
always have the luxury of whipping your
phone out you're in a conversation
um you know and something comes up
spiritually and you want to like mention
something
i'm always impressed by with some people
we've had on the show they're just like
walking the bibles
and i always thought this is neat
because there may be a time that they're
going to remove the bible hey this
thing's a hate
crime book take it away but you still
need that
in the in the brain to really like push
god's word forward so yep
so one thing that's really neat about
bible memory is they also have a bible
memory for
kids and it's very kind of pictorial you
know they kind of
use like emojis and stuff to help
trigger kids memory
it's a little bit gamified i'll say that
you know so they get like little rewards
for
you know memorizing stuff awesome um but
for our users
uh they're gonna be addicted to a game
it should be one about memorizing the
bible
yeah um for our users biblememory.com
gave us a promo code
so that you can get 20 off of their pro
version
so i encourage you guys to visit that
web address it should be in the
description below
and snag a pro copy because it's pretty
cool
um but you also might be interested in
an alternative also talk about so bible
memory you can get on iphone ipad
android kindle fire and also on the web
all right well let's talk about versus
versus is another bible memorization
tool have you heard of verses
i haven't heard that one i think this
one is only
app based so with versus
man this is so hard to read on my screen
but you can do this tap to reveal
um so the idea is you're getting getting
familiar with the text you tap on it and
it like reveals a portion of it so
you're seeing that another thing that
you can do
is you can listen to it so again
involving that auditory memory
you can do one section where if there's
a passage you can
reorder uh you have to put them in order
so to help reinforce your memory like a
word bank and you're kind of dragging
them and whether you think no that's the
next one actually is the word bank
where you it puts the certain keywords
at the bottom and you drag them into the
right spots
so that's pretty cool and then it has a
text tool where you
type in or type out the verse
you know this is kind of a neat feature
because you think of how many idle
moments you have people whip up their
phone and they're just like
flipping facebook or whatever right but
what if you're in line
and instead of playing suduko you're
sitting there going like you know i want
to learn this verse
yeah that's amazing and you can also
speak the verse they have some way of
like
analyzing your speech or something to
make sure you set it right so that's
cool
it's pretty cool um so with versus
um one of the things i'm happy about is
that
we they have agreed to give away two
subscriptions to
versus pro which is a ten dollar value
and i don't know if that's perpetual or
just a year this app was only ten
dollars
the pro version is ten bucks that's good
that's a good deal i don't know if
that's
annually or if it's one time or what
have you but
um the pro even if it's annually every
single year that's literally a dollar
a month that's 80 cents a month so let
me clarify versus is free
wow but the pro version which adds a few
more features
and i think all the features i mentioned
are included in the free version
i think just what you said uh it might
be more of a little my style you know
everybody's got a different learning
way um but i like what you said about
the
the word bank the talking it that's
that's cool
so again they're available um on lots of
different platforms
and the one thing i do need to clarify
for our audience is if you
are interested in versus and you want to
win that pro subscription
um just know that they told me
the subscription part doesn't work on
android yet so
i don't think you can get the pro
version on
android quite yet um you got to buy an
iphone
yeah and just be uh sorry iphone i'll
just keep the free one for now
um the bible also said it says in
colossians 3 16 let the word of christ
dwell in you
richly in all wisdom teaching and
admonishing one another
in psalms and hymns and spiritual songs
singing with grace in your hearts to the
lord
so aside from all the apps right
i think music and singing is a very
powerful way to memorize scripture
um so do you guys do that at all we have
little scripture songs with my kids okay
i've been learning the guitar and the
ukulele
so um with that comes you know these
little tiny jingle songs
that we've been adding scripture songs i
actually learned them from my daughter
yeah that's cool she she does a lot of
them and
you're gonna sing one for us no i'm
kidding he has shown
the o man what is good and what does the
lord require of
thee but to do justly
and to love mercy and to walk
humbly with thy god you know whatever it
is
michael six eight micah wow i'm i'm
still waiting for
uh yolanda's ten commandments project oh
yeah
i'd like to talk about that one but it's
not out yet
um so there's an app on the app store
called
scripture singer have you heard of that
one well
it's a group of students from an academy
in canada
they made this app
and they recorded a bunch of scripture
songs
so you can use the app listen to it and
then start to
memorize that scripture and there's a
whole bunch in there so
i think it also has a bible integrated
into the app so i encourage you to check
out scripture singer
and you know what a great way for young
people to use their talents you know
that's what i was just thinking like man
these are a group of kids who
you know they're singing they're
creating music and how can we help
our music to help other people and they
get connected with somebody makes an app
like man so cool and it's free so how do
you beat that
all right something else that's pretty
cool called sing
the word seeing the word uh
so we have a homeschool curriculum and i
remember we got some
cds or at least one cd as part of our
homeschool curriculum
and they were scripture songs and
you know we started to play them and i
was like wow these are really good
and i was so impressed that i went on
their website i was like what else do
you have you know and i
bought all the rest of their cds i was
like this is really neat
reasonably priced it's a christian
family the
husband and wife were both music majors
and as their little girls were growing
up
they did these wide variety of scripture
songs
multiple cd's you're talking the entire
ten commandments
psalm 91 first corinthians 13.
psalm 90 like whole chapters
of the bible in some cases they have one
cd and it's like um just a
you know a through z and they have a
scripture song for a through z
you know like every letter of the
alphabet so there's one for a one for b
one for c it's really cool so
um they're short they're catchy and
they're really well done and so i would
encourage you to check out this website
website called sing the word um
they haven't been active for a long time
but i noticed recently that they had a
new album which i've been thinking about
picking up
but they probably have a large
collection already right
uh yeah they have they have quite a bit
so you can
i think listen to samples on their
website which i should have you know
brought one on here but they
decided to give our user base a coupon
which is a little light 50 so you go to
sing the word dot com they will give you
50 off and i think it's
any any order anything
yeah so that's that's pretty good now
cds are probably like 10 bucks so i mean
five bucks you get like
10 15 scripture songs i mean that's a
pretty good deal see it's good to be a
little light
right slash in prices so
um but they also agreed to give us one
uh one user a digital download of all
of their cds um so
you know if you're a parent i think this
is a great resource for you my kids have
listened to these a bunch they have a
bunch of these songs memorized
i try to listen to them on the way to
work and refresh my memory because i'm
not as good at memorizing them as my
kids are
but yeah can't say enough good things
about them
well what about prayer have you guys
ever used an app
to help with your prayer life like a
prayer journal or like
actually using scripture like previous
pictures
no no i mean we we have a
book yeah yeah yeah well the bible says
in first thessalonians 5 17 can you
guess
and what that's what it says or whatever
first thessalonians
that's right all right yeah says pray
without ceasing and you know there's
been many people who have preached on
that topic and
basically the idea is you know be in the
attitude of prayer
at all times you know keep that
communication with god flowing there's
actually several apps out there to
enhance your prayer life believe it or
not one of the most popular ones at
least
on the apple ecosystem is called
echo and helps you pray without ceasing
as their motto
so they you get they make it so you you
can add it the
interface is very simplistic you just
tap on the one button
put it in and you know you're good to go
you can share your prayers with others
you can stay focused what does that mean
so their app when you're in it will
basically
block out other distractions
so that when you're praying that's all
you're doing that's cool you're just
praying and you can set a timer
five minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes
incidentally most
christians in the united states only
pray seven minutes a day
so you can um
follow and pray so like for your
ministry so like if our ministry had a
had echo and we could post prayers and
we could share those with other people
and
you know have lots of people praying we
should do that we probably should do
that it'd be a cool kind of experiment
you can set reminders to remind you to
pray about certain things so maybe
somebody says you know
i'm going into surgery tomorrow at 2 pm
can you pray for me
you can set the reminder pray for so you
know whatever it is like i'm thinking of
your brother who just went through
surgery
you know pray for tom at 2 p.m he's
going into surgery you can set that
it will remind you and you can keep
track of these and you can mark them
like oh yeah this one was answered
wow and yeah it's just kind of a
neat idea can you check prayed for and
it sends notification
i don't know if it sends a notification
but uh they have
a pro version which the only reason i'm
i'm really talking about the pro version
is because
they decided to give us two lifetime
memberships for echo pro
and here's some of the here's some of
the features on the pro you can create a
pair of groups barrier feeds
stats streaks weekly prayer goal
additional features
personal prayer lists prayer reminders
participating groups
follow prayer feeds post comments on
prayers group messaging
so all kinds of stuff if you're a prayer
warrior
this is probably a good app for you i've
used it uh several times
i'm not using it currently um but
um maybe i'll start again and if you uh
if you want to amp up your prayer life
this is a great way to do it you know
especially like that you know keeping
out all the other distractions while
you're praying future
so um you'll want to enter
to try to snag that there's a couple
others prayer mate is one of them
and i'll have to say i have not used
prayermate
okay i think i've used almost everything
i've talked about
so far to this point but it's very
similar to echo
in its approach um you know you can
create feeds of stuff to pray for for
ministries and churches
and it helps you with the daily prayer
discipline
and um like little reminders that pop up
yeah very easy to use very similar you
know it's just going to have a different
interface
and you know you can have lists of stuff
pack prayer packs to help your prayers
go deeper without getting repetitive
so i think it offers like suggestions of
things to pray for
or about which is kind of different than
echo
but again i haven't used that one looks
pretty good
so you might check it out and give us
some feedback let us know in the
comments below if you guys
like that one i've tried it and if it's
been beneficial to you
it's available on a wide variety of
platforms as well
and then there's pray minder some
screenshots from their website
make prayer a habit which i think is
something we should all do
it does have it's kind of funny it has
an offline version that's what they call
it offline version
they actually have this prayer journal
book that you can get from them
oh okay yeah they call that the offline
version
that's funny um anyway
how does it work keep your own prayer
list and thanksgiving list it's very
simple
uh easy to use interface again i haven't
used this one as well
um keep track of what you're praying for
notifications to remind you
you know has the dark mode which a lot
of people are interested in
it's very simplistic but this will
definitely get the job done
you know i don't think it has a lot of
bells and whistles but if you just want
to keep track of what you're praying for
it's a great way to do it yeah i mean i
have like
stuff written on receipts in my wallet
and they're fading and tearing and
that's pretty cool
yeah so cool man yeah that's cool i want
to give um
as we're wrapping this up some honorable
mentions okay some things that
i think are great uses of technology or
or or using technology to spread the
gospel
um but i didn't know quite how to fit
them in because they're not
always software some of them are
this one though the bible project
uh the bible project is a really cool
project most people have probably heard
it
that by now they're way bigger than we
are um
but yeah the bible project does these
animated
um i don't want to call them stories but
expositions on the bible all kinds of
topics whether you want to know about
heaven or hell
or i even did one on the sabbath they
have
i mean abraham and all kinds of topics
and books and
theological info they do creative videos
on it so
i'm not going to say i necessarily agree
with everything that they put out
but i will say this they have a very
creative approach to doing it i
respect their creativity um
pretty in-depth too i mean whatever
topic they're talking about they'll
talk about the greek or the hebrew or
something but what i like
is that each animation is like a
different style
and i always i always like that about
animation in general is looking at the
different styles
and so you won't get tired of the way it
looks it's very
[Music]
unique everything about it you know that
they have
an app for the bible called read
scripture
never seen that before you should check
it out it puts up a little scripture
like daily to you no it's actually a
bible
but inside the bible are
their videos oh cool so once you get to
that topic or that section so like in
genesis
it has their video about creation right
there so you can watch that
and read at the same time um
it's a pretty neat app so it's very
simplistic as far as the bible goes and
there's not like a lot of fancy bells
and whistles it just mostly has their
videos kind of baked in
as well last one i want to mention
just because i thought it was hilarious
i've never used this
[Music]
but this i used to have a bible promises
app on my phone
i used to do a fair amount of hospital
visitation
uh when i was in my late 20s early 30s
um and you know there was one lady
i think i she went eventually went from
a hospital to a nursing home
and i think i would go and visit her
with my family
almost every week for a year a year and
a half
before she passed away and
people that are in the hospital need a
lot of encouragement
and that's why i had those bible
promises there they were very
quickly accessible and i could you know
give them hope through the scriptures
but i found a bible promise website and
i just love the name of it it's called
shut up devil
i like it that is hilarious so
um i encourage you to check out shut up
devil for a bible promises app because
that's
that's what that's an interesting angle
it is it's a very interesting angle
that makes me think of uh when satan was
tempting jesus in the wilderness
exactly hit him with the word so very
clever
um love that love that concept and if
you need a bible promises app
i'm going to encourage you to check out
that one just because i like the name so
um it's competitive it's going to be
called i rebuke you
[Laughter]
yeah well that's the end of the
presentation um i encourage you guys to
check out this
link that's uh where the giveaway
is at it's just a google form so you
guys enter to win select the things that
you're interested in
winning or desiring to win and then a
week from the day that this program
airs we will select a winner and give
away all those prizes and i hope you
guys
can come away from this program with
some
extra insight maybe try a few new tools
integrate something into your
life maybe you have a struggle in one of
these areas maybe you
realize i need to go deeper in bible
stuff study and i need
you know a tool like bible study
software to help keep me going or
maybe you need something to help keep
your prayer life organized
or maybe you need to memorize the bible
and an app is a tool that you can use to
start that process so whatever it is i
encourage you to check some of these out
and we thank you guys for watching do
you have any closing comments
uh as we wrap it up if you win and
you're not going to use it
uh we can private message us we'll take
that off your hands for you
no problem and we're always available
for gift giving if you want to just
give us that we'll we will put it to use
we will
well thank you guys for watching led
live and uh we will see you on the next
program take care
[Music]
who they say can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern for
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network
show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Music]
hey
you